[Music]
there was only one thing on violet's
mind today
not a westminster circus but getting
back up line dancing
after the latest lockdown it's easy to
sit down and
moan about things you've got to get up
and
grasp them at 93 she survived covid last
year
and then from oldham watched the crisis
unfold
i suppose they try the best but
no matter what they do they'll be always
split
apple say they've done the best the
other life will say
they don't put we're not in their shoes
[Music]
everyone here knows the pain and
sacrifice of the pandemic
but they also know that they've all now
been vaccinated
and that counts and at least our country
is
the best one for the injections and
everything you know
do you think that forgives some of the
things that perhaps yeah yeah
yes i can say everybody's very good when
they've got iron sight
to me he's done the best he can it is
though the effects
of the decisions they took in downing
street that really matter
the nation's care homes endured their
darkest days
sky news witnessed it in sheffield
yeah we just didn't get the protection
you know but they failed our residents
to fail their families they've failed
our staff and
care providers across the country there
was absolutely no shield
you can't you cannot get away from the
fact that we were totally exposed
it meant places of safety became places
of danger
94 year old sheila lam had only been in
her north london care home for a few
weeks
when she caught covered during the first
wave
it's horrific to see the level of
apparent incompetence and indifference
towards the loss of life
has been particularly harrowing in the
first wave we were making decisions but
then we've repeated them
we repeated them in the autumn of last
year and many of those mistakes we're
still making now
sheila's family want the public inquiry
into the handling of the pandemic to
start soon
nothing can change the last year but we
can
learn from it tom parmenter sky news